we have a fantastic long form deep type
dive for you today on conspiracy
theories and what makes this extra
special is that it's a crossover episode
with Natanz notes the relatively new
youtube channel headed up by former TV
director on the david pakman show and my
little brother 'not on Pakman he is
voicing over and walking us through
conspiracy theories and conspiratorial
thinking on today's deep dive let's get
right into it
how do conspiracy theories work
conspiracy theories and conspiratorial
thinking are around us all the time from
eccentric friends who question whether
we landed on the moon
to the fact that a majority of Americans
believe that Lee Harvey Oswald wasn't
the only person involved in the JFK
assassination let's take a look at how
conspiracy theories work before we begin
we should clarify the difference between
a conspiracy theory and a conspiracy a
conspiracy is a fact about the world a
situation for which there's good
evidence that two or more people worked
together conspired to commit an illegal
or immoral act a conspiracy theory on
the other hand is an allegation or claim
that an event was caused by a conspiracy
a conspiracy is something that's known
as a result of investigating the causes
of an event a conspiracy theory on the
other hand is the result of rejecting
the evidence that explains an event
actual conspiracies include the plot of
Roman senators to assassinate Julius
Caesar the 1953 Iranian coup that
overthrew the democratically elected
prime minister orchestrated by the US
and the UK the Watergate break-in and
anytime two or more people get together
to rob a bank let's look at five common
characteristics of conspiracy theories
first the presupposition that nothing
ever happens by accident that chaos or
randomness does not and cannot explain
significant world and historical events
most conspiracy theorists would accept
that any one of us could get hit by a
car while crossing the street due to
completely accidental or random causes
like the driver having the Sun in their
eyes for three straight seconds right as
you cross the street in front of him but
the conspiratorial world view is that
events of major significance at least
significance to humans never occur this
way more on why this is later second the
idea of a small group of people in power
pulling the puppet strings behind the
scenes a good example of this I think is
the old anti-semitic canard of Jewish
control the core here is that there's a
cabal of Jews controlling events in
secret for their own benefit so it's
been said that Jews controlled the media
the Federal Reserve Wall Street
Hollywood that they were behind
historical Wars and revolutions and even
that they seek world domination the most
influential expression of these ideas is
the protocols of the Elders of Zion the
text was a hoax plagiarized from earlier
sources first published in Russia in
1903 and purported to be the minutes of
a meeting of Jewish leaders at the end
of the 19th century conspiring together
to take over the world it's been
debunked many times but its popularity
and influence continues to be
significant Henry Ford funded the
printing of 500,000 copies that were
distributed in the u.s. in the 1920s and
it was cited in Hitler's Mein Kampf and
in Nazi propaganda more recently it was
referenced in Hollis's charter and
continues to be read in multiple
languages and this is a feature of most
conspiracy theories that a small and
powerful group supposedly the Jews in
this particular case have orchestrated a
big nefarious scheme behind closed doors
a third common trait of conspiracy
theories is that official stories are
considered to be propaganda used by
those in power to brainwash most of the
general public think about for example
the Warren Commission report an 888 page
document submitted to President Lyndon
Johnson in September 1964 concluding
that Lee Harvey Oswald acted entirely
alone in the assassination of JFK
attacking the Warren Commission and its
report is a key feature of JFK
nation conspiracy theories one of the
main points is the single Bullet theory
often ridiculed and called the quote
Magic Bullet theory which the report
used to explain how one of the three
bullets fired by Oswald hit Kennedy's
neck and Texas Governor John Connally 's
chest wrists and thigh the supposed
implausibility of the same bullet
behaving this way is commonly cited and
was even the focus of a key scene in
Oliver Stone's JFK and a parody scene in
an episode of Seinfeld now to any of you
wondering whether only magic could
explain what this bullet did it's been
modeled and analyzed many times and
found to be completely consistent with
the laws of physics fourth skepticism
now this is actually pretty interesting
conspiracy theories often appeal to our
usual sense of skepticism but take it to
an irrational extreme they take
advantage of the fact that it's easy to
sow doubt in us simply by asking
questions that appear to expose
inconsistencies in official accounts of
events consider nasa's footage of the
Apollo 11 moon landing conspiracy loved
to point out the appearance of a waving
American flag as the pole is being fixed
into position by the astronauts they say
there's no wind on the moon so how could
the flag possibly wave now this is a
perfectly reasonable question and of
course there's also a perfectly
reasonable answer while the astronauts
place the flag on the ground it vibrated
the flagpole and flag and the inertia in
the vacuum of space led to some movement
of the flag that looked to us like
waving also the astronauts accidentally
bent the horizontal rods holding the
flag in place several times which
created the appearance of a rippling
flag in the still photographs lastly and
very importantly is the unfalsifiable
'ti of conspiracy theories if you
disprove any specific point or argument
made by conspiracy theorists they either
claim that your quote evidence is fake
and/or part of the official propaganda
story or they accept it and immediately
move on to the next point so to take the
moon landing example if you explain why
the flag appeared to be way
even a conspiracists might say yeah sure
but what about the fact that there's no
blast crater when the lunar module
landed or if you point to an aspect of
the photos that disproves their point
they answer those images were doctored
by NASA in this way
confirmation bias causes conspiracy
theorists to take any evidence you throw
at them any evidence they encounter even
evidence which contradicts their
theories and incorporate it as further
proof of their conclusion so why is it
that some people buy into conspiracy
theories we live in a world that is in
many ways full of complexity and chaos
terrible things happen for no good
reason
scientific explanations can seem
completely counterintuitive and an event
that changes history can occur by
complete accident it's difficult for a
lot of people to accept that a lot of
what happens in the world is by
coincidence or through causes outside of
our control some of these people turn to
conspiracy theories because they provide
reassurance that what's happening in
their lives or the things that we see on
the news have identifiable
incomprehensible causes there's been a
lot of research especially over the past
15 years aimed at understanding the
psychology of those who believe in
conspiracy theories conspiratorial
belief it turns out correlates with
certain personality traits such as
intellectual curiosity a strong
imagination cynicism toward politics and
distrust of authority psychological
studies have found that belief in
conspiracy theories also tends to
correlate with belief in creationism the
paranormal superstitions and New Age
beliefs conspiracism has also been tied
to a tendency to see patterns where
there are none a 20-18 study by
psychologist Joshua heart gave cognitive
tests to over 1,200 American adults and
also asked them questions about what
they thought about statements like quote
the power held by heads of state is
second to that of small unknown groups
who really control world politics and
quote groups of scientists manipulate
fabricate or suppress evidence in order
to deceive the public the
who agreed with the conspiratorial
statements were much more likely to
identify non-existent patterns when
shown randomized visual images and they
were more likely to interpret
nonsensical statements as profound so on
portions of the test that had nothing to
do with politics or conspiracies the
conspiracists tended to attribute
meaning and intention where non
conspiracists did not some researchers
have also suggested that conspiratorial
thinkers suffer from what's known as
proportionality bias in other words when
someone has trouble believing that an
event with large scale consequences can
have a small scale cause for example
that a lone gunman would assassinate JFK
that someone as famous as Princess Diana
could have been killed by a simple car
accident or that a mere group of 19
terrorists could create the devastation
of 9/11 assuming that these were all
high-level government conspiracies would
maintain the proportionality between the
causes and the consequences and it's an
understandable impulse but of course
significant events like these often do
have spontaneous small-scale causes
believing in conspiracy theories also
provides an insider sense of being in
the no conspiracy theorists and their
followers form groups that know quote
what really happened and how things
really are just think of all the
conspiracy theorists who go around Kong
people shills or sheep so although we
can understand and maybe even empathize
with what drives people to believe in
conspiracy theories it would be a
mistake to discount the dangerous
real-life consequences of believing in
them belief in conspiracy theories has
led to physical violence and terrorism
such as the 1995 Oklahoma City bombing
many people who subscribe to conspiracy
theories have a misplaced distrust or
animosity toward institutions that in
reality are beneficial to society and in
some cases they can even develop a
hatred toward entire groups of people
conspiracy theories about vaccines and
autism have led people to not vaccinate
their children against deadly diseases
and surveys have shown that people who
believe climate change to be a hoax are
far less willing to reduce their carbon
footprint the more
complex a problem is the more complex
the solution tends to be so some people
find comfort in falsely asserting
problems to be more simple than they
actually are because it would mean that
the solution is simple
if the MMR vaccine causes autism and the
medical community is ignorant about it
then the solution is simple don't trust
the medical community and don't use
vaccines it's much less palatable to
consider that autism has complicated
genetic causes that aren't yet fully
understood leaving us for the time being
with no easy answers of course you might
be watching and thinking to yourself
sometimes powerful people do conspire
sometimes the public is being lied to by
the powers that be well there's a
difference between a healthy skepticism
and habitually getting caught up in
conspiracy theories one method you might
use to tell the difference is to
consider how implausible it would be for
a huge number of conspirators to keep
everything a secret Benjamin Franklin
once wrote quote three may keep a secret
if two of them are dead physicist Robert
David Grimes has developed a
statistically rigorous formula to
determine how long it would take for a
conspiracy to be exposed based on the
number of people that must have been
involved basically the more people
involved in the conspiracy the faster a
leak would have to emerge Grimes
calculated that the supposed moon
landing hoax would require the
involvement of about four hundred and
eleven thousand people and would be
exposed within three point six eight
years a hoax about manmade global
warming would involve about four hundred
and five thousand people and would be
exposed within 3.7 years so yes some
conspiracies are real but we often find
out about them through people leaking
information and we need to be reasonable
about how improbable it would be for
there to be no leaks whatsoever over an
extended period of time
from a supposed conspiracy that involves
a great number of people another method
for finding the line between rational
skepticism and misguided conspiracism is
to employ a critical thinking principle
known as Occam's razor Occam's razor
essentially suggests that all things
being equal we should favor X
nations that require the fewest
assumptions if we already have a
reasonable explanation for why something
happened there's no need to invoke
additional speculation if your dog has a
history of digging through your garbage
and you come home and find your trashcan
flipped over it's unreasonable to start
hypothesizing about who broke into your
house to tip over your trash can
barring some specific evidence to point
you in that direction we can also
identify improbable conspiracy theories
by recognizing when a conspiracy
theorist is frequently and fallaciously
appealing to vagueness they try to
explain something complex by giving
reasons that are even more complex and
nebulous leaving endlessly branching
explanations without ever arriving at
hard facts or evidence skepticism deals
with facts proving facts describing
facts questioning facts while conspiracy
theories are generally more concerned
with attributing motives and analyzing
an event in terms of its meaning and
significance and how it fits into a
larger narrative as humans looking for
patterns is in our very nature but it's
also possible to overdo it and connect
dots that have no business being
connected and like I talked about there
are studies pointing to the notion that
there might even be broader personality
traits at play that cause people to go
down this road we have to acknowledge
that we live in an unpredictable world
filled with randomness coincidences and
accidents that can have hugely profound
consequences and jumping to
unsubstantiated conclusions about
conspiracies is almost never gonna get
us closer to understanding how things
really work or solving our problems